imagine that you're a red-blooded
carnivore you love burgers steak pork
chops bacon but one day out of nowhere
red meat starts to make you physically
sick to the stomach it sounds like
science fiction but it's real and it's
spreading it's spreading to people like
Amy my name is Amy pearl and I'm a
producer for WNYC she has what is called
a mammalian meat allergy I have a
tendency to not mention it at
restaurants because I feel like if you
say to a server like I'm allergic to me
they're gonna be like I'm spitting in
your food any meat that came from the
cow pig or a lamb will make a me sick
very very sick like I just had hives on
my hands and my feet and like all over
my torso was like nauseous and I felt
like I was fainting I felt like the
world was ending so I felt like I was
gonna pass out and I couldn't really
grieve thousands of Americans are
suffering like Amy but until 2009 this
sort of allergy went undiagnosed I think
I have made an appointment with my
regular physician but he immediately was
like there's no such thing as a mean
allergy has to be something else that
changed with the cancer drug is a
tuckson map in a clinical trial one for
patients developed severe allergic
reactions to the drug some even died
naturally so tuckson map was
investigated University of Virginia's
allergy Department focused on one
specific part of the drug a key
ingredient in seduction map is a
specific carbohydrate that all
non-primate mammals carry in their cell
walls and tissues galactose alpha 1 3
galactose or if you're pressed for time
alpha-gal dogs have it
cats have it and the micelles involved
in the production of say tux amount have
alpha gal
the team discovered that those who had
reactions were from only certain areas
of the u.s. the southeast the locations
of the cases aligned almost perfectly
with the range of a specific type of
tick the Lone Star tick dr. Scott
Commons is an allergist and was working
with the university at the time over 90
to 93 percent of our patients that
develop allergic reactions to red meat
and test positive by a blood test will
have a history of tick bites the thing I
googled was suddenly allergy I found an
article that said there was some man in
Florida had gone into anaphylactic shock
from eating meat after a tick bite and I
was like I had a tick bite I mean I'd
often have a tick bite I just taken a
tick off me one of the leading
researchers dr. Thomas Platts Mills went
so forests use himself in an unofficial
experiment taking a hike through a nest
of larval ticks it earned him a nice
case of red meat allergy there's still a
lot we don't know about how this meat
allergy works but here is the leading
theory ticks don't have alpha-gal
naturally but they could be carrying it
if they fed off a mammal like a deer or
a dog if a tick then bites you it trades
some of your delicious blood for its
saliva which is a cocktail of nasty
things an enzyme in that saliva tells
your body that there's a variety of
dangerous threats and your immune system
bans everything in that saliva from
entering the body including alpha-gal
which is also in every burger steak and
bacon strip so the next time you eat one
of those your body treats the
carbohydrate like an intruder and hits
the panic button this is happening in
the bodies of an estimated 5,000
Americans what's worse is that the range
of the Lone Star tick is growing their
range is spreading into the Ohio River
Valley and now up into Minnesota we also
know places where this alpha-gal red
meat allergy exists but they don't have
one-star ticks at all and this would be
southern Sweden for example there parts
of Europe
and now even South Africa so clearly
other tick species can do this as well
University of Virginia's researchers
have also linked the alpha-gal allergies
with a higher risk of heart disease this
allergy seems as though it will often go
away over time but the problem has been
that any additional picks might seem to
cause the allergy to return and these
are often patients who like to be
outside I know that my numbers have gone
down because I've been retested a couple
of times but they're still 10 20 times
what they should be dr. Cummings
continues to work towards an immediate
cure to mammalian meat allergy in the
meantime the number of cases are rising
so what we've been trying to do is work
on a vaccine related to tick saliva in
hopes that we can prevent the allergic
response from continuing or recurring
with additional tick bites if you've
been bitten by ticks recently be sure to
get tested if you haven't learned how to
explore the woods safely well if you
haven't been bitten then try to stick to
the trails if you're going into a heavy
tick infested area you may want to
consider pre treating your skin or
clothing with each or permethrin
respectively people are so freaked out
about ticks it's they're much easier to
see than you think
learn how to do a tick check after
spending time in the wilderness and if
you value a juicy steak over a walk in
nature then maybe stay out of the woods
[Music]